prochaine étape de levée de restrictions
en france si tout va bien ce sera le 30
juin prochain levée du couvre-feu à 23
heures à quoi bon attendre encore quinze
jours
c'est ce que se disent de plus en plus
de français au vu de ces fêtes sauvages
qui se multiplient en plus avec les
beaux jours
pourquoi attendre le 30 juin pensez vous
qu'il faut lever le couvre-feu
dès aujourd'hui on vous a posé la
question regarder pour moi il faut lever
pour tes rivaux
ça sert à rien parce que les gens ils
sont encore dehors à adé pra 10 heures
du matin et voilà qua non pour moi il
est encore il n'est pas utile parce que
23e bassidj à tard en vrai à 21h ça a
été investi encore un peu utile on parce
que les gens ils respectent et de sa
mère m'a trahi respectent plus justement
vrai de vrai à tout le monde à 23 heures
qui saurait que ça moi je pense qu'il
faudrait enlever
je pense faudrait totalement l'enlever
n'ont pas tous pas souvent mais pas tout
le temps pourquoi ce qui sert à rien un
vrai de vrai c'est tout le monde est
vacciné maintenant donc un vrai de vrai
nom je respecte pas selon moi et n'est
plus du tout utile n'ayant déjà pas
respectées souvent se couvrent cela
je trouve qu'il n'apportait peut surtout
à 23 heures sachant que les règles des
distances ne sont pas forcément
respecter tout le temps et l'horaire
n'est vraiment pas adapté pour ce genre
de virus bas selon moi il faudrait ce
prix parce que les gens ne respectent
pas en plus cela avec les boutons qui
arrivent et vacances ça va de plus en
plus difficile donc autant lever autant
enlever tout court en me répétant la
vérité dans des fois en vie mais ça
dépendra de ce que je fais si avec mes
potes on est dehors et les plus de 23h
bas on va pas dire ayvaz trois heures on
rentre on reste dehors
voilà donc non moi je pense qu'il
faudrait enlever
surtout qu'elle est match de foot qui
vont commencer le roi a commencé donc
c'est une catastrophe je pense déjà
mardi je ne sais même pas comment ça va
se passer
marc aubrière a pas de tolérance mais
enfin faut l'enlever c'est ça hein
personne ne respecte ce soit les jeunes
et deux générations donc moi je suis
contre j'ai pas traîné jusqu'à 23 heures
mais si jamais un trader chez dehors où
que j'aille dans le prendrais chez moi
et que il est 23 heures passées je
ferais je pas respecté pour moi ça n'a
aucune utilité comme le port du masque
comme beaucoup de choses qui ont été
décidées pour la
pour museler les gens quoi toi pour moi
il ya unité toute une inutilité totale
il vaudrait mieux pencher pour des soins
pour la liberté de prescrire ce qui est
ce qu'ils devraient l'être points j'ai
jamais respecter quelques couvre fait
que ce soit franchement j'ai jamais eu
de problème avec ça mais j'ai jamais
respecté non je suis souveraine de ma
vie une masse antennes je décide et
heureusement j'ai jamais été interpellé
pour ça je l'aurais contesté d'ailleurs
alors pour être honnête je pense que le
couvre-feu en soit il a aucune utilité
quand on quand on voit que le couvre-feu
19h et se défendent en six mois et il ya
eu aucune évolution par rapport aux taux
d'incidence et au taux de contamination
on se dit en fait on nous prive de
certains droits
23 heures je pense qu'à 23 heures on
devrait tous chez nous et donc
normalement pour moi ce serait même pas
un couvre-feu
mais après je peux comprendre aussi
l'agacement des jeunes qui en ont marre
ça fait quand même plus d'un an mais là
on a des lois liberticides qui sont mis
en place et on comprend pas pourquoi on
ne sait pas comment on doit juste les
respecter ils ont inventé le droit de
sortir
voilà c'est une bonne chose mais ouais
effectivement je pense fait un an et
demi rester enfermé ça va ça va deux
secondes on peut comprendre que les gens
dont en ont un peu marre mais vraiment
la vie d'avant voilà on a tous les
personnes qui étaient en faveur du
maintien de ce couvre-feu à 23 heures